now at this point I want you to remember
this volume that we did a couple days
ago okay and if you have when you drew
this diagram you might like to refer to
it but we're going to draw it again as
well search for now though let's just
have our minds for me engage rather than
concentrating on the drawing of this you
can see you might remember let me just
zoom in on this putt for you um excuse
me you can see what we're talking about
here with cutting and getting slices in
this case annulus license because you're
perpendicular to the axis of rotation
okay but if I took that same volume
right and said well what if I don't want
to cut that way what if I don't want to
cut perpendicular to the axis of
rotation the kind of opposite way the
alternative would be rather than
perpendicular I can cut his the accident
I can cut parallel to the axis of
rotation okay so rather off this way I'm
going to cut this way now every volume
is an area that's been rotated agreed so
here we've been getting these horizontal
rectangles well if I cut rather than
appendicular parallel I'm going to get
vertical rectangles here right so let's
think about this if I am if I go through
here let's pick a point like let's go
back here it's pretty bad give it time
come on so I'm just thinking a are
vertical slice out of this it's very
cool because my axis of rotation in this
case is available ok I'm going to make
it a little bit wide because it is
supposed to be a well actually I should
ask you it's a delta something right I'm
not going to zoom back out because you
know i'm going to muck up where my
position is but over here you can just
see little bit that's going to be a
delta y do you agree right so here I'm
going to have a delta X ok but remember
i am still rotating this way still reach
me this way so when i take this guy and
I rotate this way what kind of shape do
I create well here's what I'm going to
do I want you to imagine I didn't have
this whole yellow thing right take away
all the other stuff just
cus on this black pine right well this
pie is going to retain a cross and
become kind of like this this planet the
top is going to do exactly the same
thing it's going to retain around and
it's going to be a part of Ireland seat
in the back right and then over here
I've kind of got the opposite part of it
now don't forget this is just a slice
it's a vertical slice right so therefore
this thing is actually hollow right this
is like the inside okay so we have a
name for this we have a neighborhood
we've already said if you take this kind
of shape and imagine it as
infinitesimally then we call this an
annular slice but this is not a slice at
all it's not flat in any way okay what
you have instead is what we call a
cylindrical shell okay so you can see
the cylindrical shape but it's holler
right it has to be Hollow because you're
rotating something that is
infinitesimally thin ok does that make
sense now here's all the powerful thing
about anyone's license right annular
slices we know what the area of an
annual slices the cross-section and if
we just multiply by your Delta X or
Delta Y or whatever and you get the
volume okay this thing looks like it's
going to be well of similar complexities
in terms of working at the volume of
this thing except it's not it's way way
simpler if you just are willing to do a
bit of deconstruction right so if i take
this shape right and i just cut it along
the axis all right in what you end up
with is a marvelously simple shape this
is just the rectangle just to maintain I
already know about the width of a news
or the thickness i should say it's delta
whatever in this case delta x okay so
all i need for the volume of this theme
or rather the cross the area the cross
section ears I need to know how tall it
and then I need to know how white it is
it's just
rectangle right now in order to work out
well okay where are these things coming
from on mine right I know how tall it is
but how I work out this width and the
answer is you just have to remember back
to where the shape came from right the
shape came from a cylinder which is just
it's just a circle isn't it it's just a
circle right so therefore let's think
about this you remember we said here you
go through said you can take this thing
you can muck about with it you can make
it anything you like let's think about
what this is going to be because of all
you again just like you told it before
right the width of this thing is I've
Delta X right because it's a little bit
I should say that little bit is
horizontally origin okay i'm going to
add up now just for this particular one
where am i going where is the smallest
of these cylindrical shells that's
what's visible and the answer is it's
down here this is tiny little
cylindrical shell with no volume yes so
x equals zero is where I'm going to
begin where do I end where's the biggest
cylindrical shell just that like I
probably ought to do now i should say i
should say this Exodus X I'm actually
taking there a shortcut what they really
are maybe I should have written this is
actually a radius right it's the radius
of a cylindrical shell its getting
bigger and bigger and bigger okay now
what's happening in here well I just
need to know the volume of this thing
which comes from the area of this thing
do you agree okay now you told me there
was the edge here which comes from the
circumference at the top which is just 2
PI R and that's the circumference right
and then what was the other thing I need
I need I and then I need the Delta X
like which is actually a radius the
radius is what's changing
okay right now this is really good this
is really really good I want to tighten
this up a little bit because in fact in
our case in our case Delta R is changing
horizontally so it easy in fact the
Delta X that's why I kept on writing and
then rubbing up so I can now replace in
a similar way to how we did it yesterday
right sometimes your Delta is Delta X
Delta Y Delta R Delta H whatever are
equivalent to each other so I'm changing
everything in terms of exes because it's
convenient to me yes it would be change
the top one the Sigma under the seat huh
wouldn't that be a loser okay remember I
can choose whatever boundaries I like I
was going to choose X boundaries all the
time because i'm looking at like i'm
integrating over this interval and i
don't have like it's in misting here I
don't know what r is its variable that I
don't know what it is yet right so
therefore it sort of doesn't matter yeah
which one is going to be this as a
person when we were first meeting
integration by substitution here we have
to be a little more comfortable with
having things where the integrals are
mixed are the variables are mixed and we
have to sort of resolve we have to go
through steps to try and get it all in
terms of one variable ok now just pause
for a moment what have we just
established now we're going to work out
this volume we actually already know
this won't though right we calculate
this like a couple of days ago I invited
be better and this is the heading in
case you on wanted earth why might it be
better to think about this as a
cylindrical shell rather than let go
where's my own you much less going it's
done a disappearing the other one when
it disappears all it's gone well it is
in business with your husband be
surprised okay is it any better what
would leave me just think cylindrical
slices rather than any other slices what
might leave me to think that there's
something on the board that tells me
there's a wise yeah
okay yeah very good so the first thing
is I don't have to do member when we
were actually doing this volume we had
to do some serious risks and turns you
had to do a lot of like all look there's
this branch and then with this branch
and it's just like your head start to
her right so that's the first thing
there's this another simple thing right
which is that look at this just compare
this with having an I squared minus a
squared right just by virtue of squaring
you make whatever you had there it's
going to be a key and we even had square
roots even after squaring okay so it's
going to be like yeah I'm gonna have
some messy algebra or is here look at
these these are so nice and simple right
and it's going to be even simpler once
you recognize what H's what is H it's
just the vertical coordinate right it's
just why and why is how I believe this
was taught me remember i think it was 4x
squared minus x to the 4 i think so look
it's just a polynomial and that's just
the polynomial this is super super easy
to integrate